how many times have I told you that I
can't pick up on you every day really
how many times have I told you that I
can't take you less Jeff Jeff I'd like
you [ __ ] week in a row every [ __ ]
day Robin Robin brings up a good point
tell my audience tell my audience what
we met go Bo yeah all right now I'm on
the phone with you your complaint seems
to be that I don't pick up the phone
enough on you I think I do I think the
audience gets a smattering of you what I
want to say to you is this in a calm way
I like you I think you're part of you
know the the fabric of the show you're
important to me because I have somehow
puts you in the whack pack but you know
that means yeah and actually when I
don't pick up on you you can't take it
so personally I'm conducting a radio
show for a lot of people you understand
it's not about you I do understand what
is it truly what's going on with this
guy
you're being a little too hard on
yourself Howard because what you may not
realize is the topics he's been calling
in with I mean that you haven't picked
up and I have a list of good what is it
that's why I said what did we miss yeah
one ball that Howard dropped was when
Jeff called in with the news that his
doctor visit went well and he got blood
work done yeah nobody cares on the air
Wow
but you bet if they were bad results and
you would said have got three weeks to
live that would have been good there's a
home run yeah hearing that you're fine
is not a homerun for me it's good for
you for different times he called them
to talk to you about the Brady Bunch
house renovation right over the past and
that's another thing when
talking about that I was dialogue to
that you got a big double German what
did you have to say well I would have
[ __ ] I just wanted some quick endo
about you know the very budget all that
well give us the antidote right now no
well I don't have oh how about when you
didn't pick up on this one hour and this
was a big one his deck was built he
dealt learn to tell you about yeah I
mean Jeff these aren't great topics and
by the way I'll still pick up on you
from time to time okay but don't get all
bent out of shape like I hate you or
something because you're not being
picked up on he's buying
he's buying [ __ ] to get on the air to
like one of his topics was Tommy John
ugh geez feel great yeah see Jeff you
used to be funnier we'd have you down
here and you'd be so she used to be
funnier when you'd come down here so
shit-faced drunk that's right we can't
serve you alcohol here so you you come
in yeah and I in fact I'm proud of you
that you're not drinking as much I don't
want to encourage you're drinking what I
like I know you like to drink so you
come down here in your sober the last
time I had you up here for the backpack
Conclave and then the last time I had
you down here for the whack pack
Conclave you walk in the studio high and
you barely said a word I do believe that
but you [ __ ] just tell us what's on
your mind you high [ __ ] what
yeah when he talks it just sounds like
cars going
what's that oh you're right it is like a
car running by
you